okay the question is
[Music]
uh how do i am not pushing i'm not
fully um
and let me add to the question
i think clothing dependent is also not
correct i think we do these things
because
we're missing key energetic
skills and i'll explain those in a
minute but
uh clothing dependency and then limb
dependency
that's never a good thing so
we have a lot of turning like uh
grabbing cutting here and kind of
push full turn the guy
we don't we don't want that okay
there are also clashes so
if i go here and i pull this guy
uh that's a clash he's going that way
and i'm trying to take him that way
that's a clash that's not the art
and secondly you're going to have to
have a choreographed 2k
so when i go like this and i pull the
guy
don't don't do anything and i pull him
he would fall like that
but every uk he'll turn
because he knows that's what he's
supposed to do and that's not
good either you have to
you have to think of the problem
differently
those questions are arising because
of how you're understanding the question
those questions cannot be answered
and be consistent with the art it's the
question itself is wrong
okay so the energy that you're looking
for
is not generated or not able to be
generated
from a linear entry
you have to generate beforehand
the centrifugal energy so if this is
uh his head neck area
you're not pushing this like that
you're not pulling it like that this
ball is
traveling on a circle let's say it's
going that way
um and i'm going to come around and i
can without holding the ball
keep it in my control so
i come around here you see i've changed
the x y already
your question you didn't
so from the get-go i changed it
and i now use that same ball technique
i don't want to go here he stopped
now there's no energy
so his energy goes here and i keep that
thing going
energy's going here and i'm in that
if you wait the energy stops and you're
back now in the other problem
so his energy goes that way
and as soon as he moves there on here
and i'm already rotating
not after too late it's not going to be
energetic
so in
and just like if i was doing it on the
ball
open your hand don't keep your hand here
i don't know which part i'm going to be
able to manipulate
energetically so open your heart
open your hand and be in a place
where the slack isn't taken out with the
turn of his head
so i go over here you're going to lose
it so i'm kind of
here on the neck mandible area
turn your head i still have it you see
i'm not in the front
here
and i'm doing it there again
so he stands up and i'm here
doing the same kind of energetic
manipulation
okay okay so he's going that way i'm
in
i'm not torquing him
controlling his head you know these are
all
external solutions to a missing skill
set
you have to do this just like the key
grab all right
let's get to here same thing here
he gets up look what i'm using i'm using
my body as a lever
again an external solution
to a missing skill set so this energy
i'm bringing around this energy i'm
bringing up
the problem with external solutions is i
have to be strong enough
i have to be stronger if i am going to
control his head
it requires that i'm actually strong
enough to control his head
same thing here yes this this
body is a greater lever
than no energetic skill and trying to
use one hand
but you still have to be stronger than
the resistance you're trying to move
we're doing something different here
so pay attention hal i'll have to keep
him moving
go back to the first problem
this fight has to start rotating
you're like that's weird no you know
what's weird is the 12
6 line is weird that's a weird thing
okay there's many ways that you can
start
a fight rotating the first deviation
so he throws whatever boom he's going to
come at me again
isn't he a fight's rotating you see
so does it again he deviates we're
rotating now
it's not uncommon what's uncommon he
throws the strike
this is uncommon
fights rotate all the time this one is
aggression
this is not a self-defense situation i'm
not doing a
wrist grab defense
i'm understanding that
so that i can understand this
not here no this is
not external manipulation
so he goes this way i go this way
oh and i do it again and you can see the
force that i can
generate by just using that same trick
on the
on the throw part right so here it comes
way boom without the grab
right here you don't need to grab
his energy and the pattern all creates
the necessary friction the energetic
adhesion is as as he comes in
and he keeps moving that way i take
advantage of this circle
so i don't stick a new linear line
into this and then reach
this is still
a clash
so he starts the rotation and i keep the
rotation going
you have to change how you
oh he goes here and i pass him
here rotate rotate rotate
he also as i said he has to keep moving
so if i don't keep the rotation going
i won't do it i'll be pushing and
pulling
but if i do keep if i do get the
rotational angle
and we stopped it's not it
so this is coming in
you have the first blend and you can use
this hand
with your adhesion on this side
here i'm not cutting here on the inside
of his arm
this adhesion on this side
it that is the tougher adhesion
but you see how it keeps it moving
[Music]
so let's just do the first part he keeps
moving
keeps moving behind him
so let's say i jack up
i can't adhere here he's done
moving you can keep it going from here
in you see that's enough energy i did
not get any
that's how important and how different
it is to go here
and then do a head control
he has to keep moving
keeps moving
so if you look my mind is different
i want him to keep going forward i don't
want him to go backwards
i don't want him to tilt
he's here keeps going
okay uh the prescription is um
this technique is a spinal displacement
okay so i'm not here holding his wrist
um there's a linear aggression to it
and it's again coming from the same
internal skills that he's using as
as uh nagi so i'm here
and i'm able to move him by projecting
his center
so to do that i'm not pinning myself
it's not this
i i am i am as mobile as as
anything so um to stand up i would have
to put my weight
on the balls of my feet and uh that's
the same ground vectors not my knees
it's the same ground vector up here so
you can stand up
and and move can you see that
i'm not i'm not in mobile okay so
uh when he
creates what you think is a void
if i wasn't doing the bracing angle he
goes with the void abrasion angle i do
that and i lose my grip
but if i was doing the same ground
vectoring
when i pushed in there he creates the
void i would move in
my whole body would move it
and that doesn't change when i get on
the ground azuki
so is he i'm trying to push he's
reconciling my whole body with movement
that's what you're seeing him do he's
not leaning out there
and then he's doing that that kind of
thing saying he's not doing the
prescribed attack
so let's try to have that
uke fix that the second thing
is he has to keep moving
some mukesh can't do that they're not
mobile enough
but you can keep moving him with this
adhesion here
okay it is a harder adhesion than the
one using centrifugal energy
it works on the same principle but it's
not using
the same energy sources
okay
if it does stop when i come here
it's the same same thing from here i can
move his center
so in the same way that i'm moving his
center there
on the void i'm not just getting out of
the way and he falls into it
there is an acceleration
and the same way that this is just an
arm move
it keeps that center going room this
energy is going
it's the same thing if i have to when i
get here
the action stop don't push into
his head and arm push into his
center to keep it going
that way i'll have a chance if this
thing slows down
that i can still do the correct
uh initial rotational geometry and
generate the adhesion
through centripetal centrifugal energies
okay
now this check
this arm thing that you're doing is so
common
you're trying to push pull turn the
steering wheel
this is not marshall if i'm on the
outside
i'm on the outside of the elbow not on
the inside
so if he had a knife i'm checking his
at his elbow he's trying to stab me it's
hard for him to
find different angles because i can keep
sticking to that elbow
if i'm on the inside like this it's hard
for me to control what that knife is
doing
you're always on the outside of the body
you're on the outside of the elbow
number on top never on the inside
and hence it's not part of the kazushi
i'm not going like
this
the energy is keeping them going forward
and in that end is the outward
that i'm using on this adhesion
again if i don't have the energetic
principles i got to come up with some
external inferior thing
but to stop to gain the internal
i got to stop the external i got to stop
it so i'm going to put my hand on the
outside
it's on the outside of the elbow i keep
this going
and start
outside keep it there it stopped
i'll have to get it going again
in push it in
you